I want to focus on the business model
and and what users are looking for right
so so just just at a very high level uh
we'll we'll keep it
so yeah this is gut health and The
Unsung story of good bacteria right
um we all know how gut helps and what
kind of function it does right so it
basically helps in absorption and
production of nutrients it's it it
seventy percent of the immune system
resides in the gut so it's a big defense
mechanism for us and then and you know
it also eliminates a lot of waste
products which are not needed in the
body and as we all talk about you know
how the gut and brain axis are connected
and most of the time we say when you are
uh you know uh you have mood swings or
not in a good mood we say you know it is
connected to gut health so you should
you should eat something nice and that's
what you you also feel right when you
eat something nice you're suddenly uh
your mood you know becomes better or you
start feeling better so there's a big
connection between the gut and brain
axis
and also uh the the how the mental
health is completely connected to your
gut health if your gut is not good there
would be a lot of mental health issues
what may be the science of poorly
functioning that we we all know but we
really like you know don't uh much talk
about the gut health we know that you
know how uncomfortable digestion
sometimes we have we have Transit
disorders IBD you know diarrhea
constipation poor nutritions and
absorption poor immunity these are all
signs and symptoms of not having a a
good gut or a poorly functioning gut
right mood swings smooth depressions uh
General fatigue Sleep Disorders
abdominal pain discomfort so if we I
mean generally we you know try to to
relieve the symptoms but one should look
at you know what's happening at a gut
level
uh so I would like you know just just
keep it very high level that what are
the different composition of the gut
microbiome and as you might have already
gone and seen uh through your the you
know uh uh in your last pres uh sessions
that there are four major groups of
microorganisms which are available in
the gut abundance of these
microorganisms are there as bacteria
archaea viruses and eukaryotes and in
among all you know and you can see that
how bacterias are the most abundant ones
looking at their percentage which varies
from 1990 to 99 compared to the other
ones
so how do we you know basically uh
categorize these bacterias or or the
individuals who have these bacteria so
this is called enterotypes and we have
three major enterotypes type one type
two type three so type one people are I
mean the the individuals who are who are
categorized as type 1 enterotype are
basically who uh you know they they are
rich in privatola they have privateola
dominant types and they mostly consume
carbohydrates right uh come and then
then coming back to this type 2 which is
basically bacterioids they have a lot of
they they have the abundance of
bacterioids and and uh they take high
intake of animal protein and fats
basically what we call and call as the
Western diet and if you look at the
graph you can see how it is you know
changing between the privatola
bacterioids and rominococcus and the
type 3 which is the rominococcus
dominant type which is uh you would find
more in people who who consume a lot of
diet which is rich in dietary fibers So
based on these different
uh bacteria bacterial type basically
people can be categorized in these three
different enterotives
and why we need to categorize people on
enterotiles because to to basically
apply any strategies in in Precision
Nutrition you would you would first need
to characterize these individuals so if
you look at these three individuals who
are ABC uh are being characterized based
on their uh phenotype which is basically
the gut enterotype so what bacterias
abundant they have and then categorize
them on those you know uh type 1 type 2
type 3 and then based on that you
suggest nutrition probiotic Prebiotic or
any sort of you know life's uh lifestyle
changes so so that's that becomes more
uh
personalized or precision based you know
nutrition which is uh which has really
not been you know implemented in current
scenario uh but this is how it has to be
done to you know to to to get it the the
maximum advantage of any probiotic or
Prebiotic when you actually know that
what is the already abundance level